I'm gonna ask you some question fresh
it's when you say you know what this is
me like I'm good at it yeah good this is
thumbs up as down exactly I know when I
go on the the Rotten Tomatoes all the
time and I see you know how many
freshers they're on there let me read
the good reviews I'd like to leave
plenty of time for myself safety is the
big thing I don't like to go fast I
don't get any big thrill out of it and I
get it thrill out of getting to where
I'm going in one piece must go faster
[Music]
I'd give myself a 67 percent I'm on it
too much but I I don't do it when I'm
crossing the street
good job oh there it is
fresh because even though everything
looks good I'm on the job I'm trying to
do good things and break records but I
love music and I think that's the only
qualification for what's called good is
if you like it you know yeah I'm pretty
good when I get to a chance to be on you
parklandia
you know and work with those wonderful
people or with Taika Waititi once again
I don't know found good I am but I love
it I saw every episode of Breaking Bad
and I binge watched that but no I don't
do it that much so then you're rotten oh
I guess I'm kind of rot rotten beep beep
beep beep beep I'm coming around no
drive defensively always be on the alert
for people that are gonna be doing crazy
things
[Music]